my name is NaN Chanda I'm editor of Elle
global online we are delighted to have
with us in our studios
dr. Gro Harlem Brundtland the former
Prime Minister of Norway from treating
patients to organizing public health to
running government as Prime Minister and
leading the charge for economic
development and World Health dr.
Brundtland has done it all her nickname
in Norway is mother of the nation a
physician by training dr. Brundtland
studied public health at Harvard
University and was appointed prime
minister at the age of 41 and she was
the first woman Prime Minister and 1st
and the youngest Prime Minister of
Norway
she served three times as Prime Minister
of Norway and then she was appointed
chair of the world Commission on
Environment and development that
commission known as Brundtland
Commission has been a a key player in
the development world economic
development that has followed and she
developed the concept of sustainable
development in the report that she
submitted in 1987 in 1998 dr. Brundtland
took over as a director general of World
Health Organization and since then she
has held several position as the special
envoy of the UN secretary-general and
one of the dramatic moments of her life
was in 2011 when she narrowly escaped
death when a hundred frantic fanatic
killer Anders Behring Breivik
wanted to heat to grow as he said but
instead he killed several dozen students
who had just heard a speech by dr.
Brundtland
so dr. Brundtland you are you have done
so many things that is difficult to know
where to begin but let's begin with your
interest in medicine and how that became
a kind of people hotel think for you to
join the government and eventually
become Prime Minister so what attracted
a young child I grew up with a father
who was a social democratic politician
and later on Minister but but he was a
doctor and a specialist in
rehabilitation medicine so already as a
ten year old we went the family my
brothers and I with my father and mother
to the US where he had a fellowship at
the Rockefeller Center studying
rehabilitation medicine so I went to
fifth grade in Brooklyn New York which
of course you know you learn your
English early and you then the question
was what kind of professional life
should I choose what education for a
long time I thought yes I'm going to be
a doctor but I talked in my mind then
about a doctor that can improve Society
and not a doctor thinking in terms of
separate each individual patient but a
doctor thinking about societal change so
that's why I also studied Public Health
Authority now that again when you think
further in my life when I was asked to
become minister of the environment
immediately I thought oh my goodness the
Prime Minister is asking me that not to
be Minister health which is my own
profession but it didn't take much
reflection to realize that why are we
interested in protecting the environment
because of the health of people first of
all so the links between public health
medicine biology nature
and the protection of planet Earth and
environment is obvious yeah yeah so so
after serving as minister of environment
then you are appointed Prime Minister
and yes but first a parliament first I
became a parliamentarian for a short
period which was important because then
I knew the Parliament before I became
Prime Minister yeah so after you are
appointed they to chair the Commission
on Environment development how many
people worked with you to develop this
concept of sustainable development well
you know I had this five year period of
being a minister environment for Norway
and of course every area about certainly
environment is international so I
traveled and worked with ministers from
other parts of the world and from other
parts of Europe so I got international
experience and then in when you had you
had had the Stockholm conference in 1972
two years before I became Minister that
was the first environment conference
globally and it became a real break down
between different parts of the world and
different types of countries because the
West had already experienced the danger
of pollution and they raised the issues
about the environment in the developing
world and the poor world they said what
are you talking about we need to
overcome poverty people are hungry so
India Indira Gandhi came to Stockholm in
72 and said poverty is the greatest
polluter and that Illustrated the big
drama of difference between different
parts of the world on this issue now as
we then come up to around 1982 countries
started to discuss how should we bring
together and
and development issues in such a way
that it becomes a global concern because
it is still a very crucial issue and it
has to be dealt with nobody has thought
about climate change at that time
however the environmental issues were
adding up the trends were bad so in 1983
a group of countries I think convinced
the secretary-general to create a new
global Commission and they asked me to
chair a commission on the environment
but it listed population pressures
poverty under development all the
challenges of the world that we were
going to look into given the chapeau of
environment so and I said first of all I
said I can't because I'm a leader of the
Opposition in Norway you know how can I
do this he said you are the only
Environment Minister who have become
Prime Minister I need you to do this and
I had to give him I couldn't give him an
alternative so I when I took on that but
I said to him you know I cannot deal
with environment without having
development fully on the table and
without having at least half the members
of the Commission from the developing
world otherwise we will never see eye to
eye on environment issues unless they're
linked to the development challenges so
it already started in the face of
building up the Commission and for me
selecting the other members so then we
work together 23 members for three years
and gradually developed the concept but
from the beginning I had called the
Commission the world Commission on
Environment and development which then
made a big difference to the whole of
the developing world as they saw these
analyses starting from another point the
linkage between development and yeah and
so even surely the idea of planetary
boundaries developed that in the
absolutely
in the trends where the dramatic already
and the analysis and and we solved the
world expertise in every area of
resource allocation and in the different
areas of so you know economic growth etc
so in very briefly what does this
concept sustainable development mean
what is to be sustained and what is
development so what it means is given
that there are environmental constraints
and limits to what we can do on planet
earth there is no question that this is
the case we have to change the patterns
of development that have led to the
environment being threatened long term
and forever now that how do you change
the pattern or development in a way that
is sustainable to all to also take care
of people's needs that participation
that you can take into consideration the
environmental limits but still have a
sustainable pattern of economic
development and it's on the ring you
know that can create human rights basis
for everybody and sustainable for future
generations and that's the second that's
the second main point because then it
became clear and it had really never
entered into people's minds before that
we were the first generation my
generation to see that what we do today
has ever lasting consequences if you go
hundred years back or more you know two
generations back from me everybody saw
that if we do things now that doesn't
mean that a generation or two from now
they cannot make other choices but that
was no longer the case in the twentieth
century because what we did the
footsteps of humanity started you have
ever lasting consequences and so we were
responsible for future generations
for the first time in a very real sense
yeah so the the later concept of
planetary boundaries and climate change
becoming irreversible all this is
natural outgrowth of that idea that you
planted there all right and they and we
warned already in the report about
global warming their danger of fossil
fuels the danger of co2 emissions it was
all there so already 87 the world was
warned about this yeah and it was only a
couple of years later that well in the
preparation to Rio Rio
five years after report came we prepared
the climate convention to be signed by
that meeting in 92 it was already an
urgent issue so looking back what has
happened since 92 has it not been a bit
disappointing in terms of despite all
their awareness what yes a yes it has
been disappointing to you in many ways
but when you look at the situation where
the global impact of humanity's choices
is it is what is at stake it means all
development patterns in every country
every political decision being made and
private sector you know investments all
of it effects the future of sustainable
development so it's not surprising that
it takes a generation to really start
moving on the issue and this year 2015
because of I mean the Secretary General
has helped I would say to pull together
the Sustainable Development Goal
thinking
which is going to be next to the
Millennium Development Goals from 2015
forward and the climate issue which now
so far ends in Paris in 2015 so in
September in the General Assembly the
sustainable development goals will be
decided upon and in December comes the
climate negotiation results so it is so
they are brought very closely together
and they are more closely together in
people's minds so one of the things that
happened in all the process of
negotiations on the new sustainable
development goals was that there was
conflict on many issues between types of
countries but in the end with the 17
goals that have been prepared climate
change is placed in the middle of those
goals to deal with climate change also
the gender issue the fact that women
have been discriminated against in
development and in human rights terms
yeah ever since history started I'm
guessing but still a challenge that has
been put in an energy the use of energy
has to be sustainable all of these
crucial issues within sustainable
development and climate or know within
those 17 premièred goals mm-hmm
talk about women you have been a
champion of women's cause and in fact
one of the things you brought attention
to was the question of breastfeeding the
importance of breastfeeding and so
looking back do you think that this has
had some positive impact just like
people are more aware of this it has
saved many children's lives that's for
sure because what I saw as a young
student at Harvard was that the trends
in breastfeeding across the world which
I studied in my main thesis that year
they showed that there was a reduction
in men
countries of the world including the
poorest ones where you really need to
see to him that the babies are breastfed
and it was a consequence of many things
also ideas spreading from a rich world
where mothers started getting convinced
by industry why don't you have a bottle
much simpler you can go to work and use
the book and it's equally good as the
they said in the beginning and you had
to prove that this is not the case so I
remember at a year at Harvard we went to
Jamaica on a study tour and there at
that time a poor country the the women
were watching American TV and they were
poor and they stopped breastfeeding
because they saw these American
beautiful well-dressed women you're
having their baby with above the bottom
and what happens in the poor country you
have dirty bottles they are not
sterilized you had you know deaths from
diarrhea for from from babies and
increasing child mortality so yes it was
it has been important and then many
years later as I am Prime Minister 1981
the first discussion in the World Health
Organization about this issue about
having a code of conduct with regard to
advertising of infant formula came and I
gave support from Oslo to the Health
Minister spoke out about it and then as
I came to w80 98 this was established
process that the w-h-o who had its
advice and its principles to share
across the world about this yeah now
that to measure inequalities well maybe
more than that but one is this gender
inequality which is still very rampant
and the second is economic inequality
which is
somehow reduced in the developing
countries thanks to increasing trade and
development but the developed countries
are fils seeing a situation where the
middle class is hurting an economic gap
is growing how what is your thought on
that this the second gender inequality
and economic inequality well first of
all that you are linked mm-hmm because
in countries where poverty prevails and
development patterns are still not as
they could have been you see generally
most places that women are girls and
girls are treated unequally they are
seen as supporters of the male the
father is supposed to have the food the
brothers are supposed to have the food
instead of the girls etc so this this so
this inequality of in economic terms and
gender terms softened very hard strongly
linked now why why has it happened that
if you use us as an example that the
middle class that was rising and getting
their kids educated getting reasonably
well you know taken care of in health
terms in the last 50 years nearly now 45
at least it has been more of a stagnant
situation for the middle class
they haven't had increase in real terms
while the rich part of the population
have moved ahead now I think it's a
difficult analysis and many people who
do research in economics and so on as
including Piketty has been you know
addressing the issue why has it happened
what is it I remember 20 years ago when
I was in the middle of my prime minister
period I saw that there was already a
big difference
inequality in Norway was among the
lowest in the world
and it was increasing in the US and I
and and it was larger in the first place
and the trend was getting worse so for
instance CEOs would at that time earn 30
times what their workers were doing and
in Norway they would earn maybe four or
five times then their workers and I said
to myself why on earth has a CEO 30
times the wage level as I couldn't
understand it
if you look at this today in Norway you
may have kind of a 5 times mm-hmm but in
the u.s. it's hundred times it's it's
getting completely all online and
impossible now the dynamics behind this
and why does it happen to this extent
certainly its lack of political
determination in my mind I mean we have
been struggling in Norway to improve
equality and to fight against
inequalities if you don't do that
systematically as a politician this is
what happens yeah yeah yeah the tax
system yeah has every completely skewed
advantage of the rich absolutely yeah
and so it doesn't have to be like this
this is my point this can be changed
around it's not something that nature
decides right but you have to have
politicians with values and with a
vision but there is connection in the
sense that some of the very rich people
are also climate deniers climate change
they sit on investment in coal right you
know it's not really yeah
very cool and fossil fuels yeah yeah but
yes but you know yes coal plus but coal
is kind of the big the big issue here
and and so as co2 has become a
dramatically negative thing with regard
to emissions people who have coal
resources and have invested in the coal
industry they have been in the front
yeah to create the deniers that's what I
mean yeah we know that yeah just like
the tobacco industry did yes when we
started from the public health community
to push back push back tobacco yeah they
started you know raising money yeah to
undermine the arguments is the same
thing yeah yeah yeah so and the economic
difficulties that the West especially
United States and Europe faced since
2008 nine crisis also had increased the
inequality because people could not cope
with the crisis in equal fashion which
did very well and the poor sank even
further and that situation also in
Europe is having very dramatic
consequences in social life and so I
would like to hear your views on the
anti-immigrant movement that is
beginning in Europe very strong and they
are becoming politically more
influential especially in the light of
what you experienced yourself in in Oslo
when in 2011 Andrew Breivik who wanted
to actually kill you and he ended up
killing some students yeah I you know I
think he planned both yeah it wasn't
that since he didn't get me he killed
the students yeah he planned to kill
young Social Democrats but also kill
their most important leader in his mind
in his life which was me the leader of
the Labour Party and the Prime Minister
as he grew up so because he
blamed the social democracy and and me
as its leader
for having changed Norway to of what he
called a feminist sate because we had
let women get more and more equal
opportunity with men in his mind it was
wrong because men should be the dominant
that was this idea secondly he he was
very adamantly against any immigration
to Norway which will change the
Norwegian population from a white male
dominated society to a cultural mix this
was wrong in his mind so what it was
after was he thought of himself as a big
you know visionary hero that would with
his attack have people realize how
terrible the situation was yeah so this
but it was his crazy mind you know but
you have extremist people and movements
not big ones but they are there in
Europe and other places that think in
such terms yeah so but from that so this
is a more of a special case but of
course when when after the financial
crisis of 2008 onwards many people
became unemployed in Europe you get more
of attention among those who have been
hit by difficulty to look around them
and say why do we have these foreign
people coming from different parts of
the world taking our jobs so this kind
of aspect then enters into their into
the minds of people more easily when
there is difficulty yeah the other thing
is also that as many have entered into
Europe European societies have changed
and it has happened over
a short time period only in kind of two
generations not over centuries you know
but but quickly and people start asking
is this right and then so parties in the
Nordic area that have been arguing
against immigration for years they never
got more than a few percentages or maybe
top 10% of the vote until I remember in
Norway in 1989 the probe so-called
Progressive Party came above 10% and all
of us I was in charge I oh I was the
Prime Minister but also the Conservative
Party and other parties in Norway the
bigger traditional parties got scared I
mean how do we deal with this because
the policy was an open-minded kind
policy of letting asylum seekers enter
Norway and to protect them you know and
give them benefits and help them get
along but then you you you we had to
start discussing the issues that this
party raised yeah because it was no
longer possible to just disregard them
you had to start arguing with them and
this is what happened in Sweden
just a few two years ago when they had a
parallel situation a party that all of a
sudden got up to 12 or 13 percent and
all the other parties were shocked I was
not shocked because we had seen it 25
years before it happened 25 years later
in Sweden now they have to relate to
this party and discuss with it you know
you can't make as if 30% of the people
can just be forgotten right so the when
you started opening the door for
immigration
it was mostly humanitarian yes but now
economic need is there for
bringing people who have either skills
or maybe unskilled but who are willing
to do dirty work and that is what is
happening in many of European countries
she put in the Scandinavian countries we
have stayed completely with the
humanitarian approach so it has been
very difficult for Norwegian or Swedish
companies to have people foreign workers
specialists come and serve at high-level
positions or in expert positions because
our policy is the ones we open the door
for are those who need protection
because of being persecuted in their
countries and so on so we have not made
it easy for Norwegian industry hmm
so yeah so we this is a paradox compared
to Canada for instance people they take
in people that Canada Canadian companies
can benefit right for us this is not you
know for Norwegians and politicians in
Norway this is unethical this is not
right we should take care of those who
are sick poor persecuted and of course
it also leads to the sum of all those
decisions yeah that you have big
populations of people who are on
benefits who need the benefits more than
the Norwegian people and then you have
no witness saying why are we tax payers
paying for all these because it's
there's a lot of dilemmas mm-hmm
but say in Germany the majority of the
Islamic population are Turks who are
brought in to actually run the factories
and so now they and their relatives have
come and the number has grown and so but
for a long time in Germany all the
politicians agreed on one thing these
were foreign guest workers yeah they
were not accepted yes so it was a
different policy
but gradually they couldn't keep that
yeah you know it didn't work so as you
say the families came the sons and
daughters were born and gradually they
had to change the Posie yeah and the
same same thing in in France yes
same thing in France and so these
countries they are now facing this
political challenge like different
National Front in France is rising very
fast and so the kind of problem you
first 25 years earlier they are there
yeah in the UK in France and Germany yes
yeah so in that sense you know the state
is immune from this because of the
different history yeah I mean it was a
conglomerate and a mix of people from
many places from the very beginning so
or very early yeah so it's a very
different scenario yeah yeah so just go
back to last question about the coming
Paris summit on the climate change what
do you expect this summit to produce do
you think that there'll be an
enforceable Accord reached I you know
the degree of enforceable or degree of
legally binding it's an important
question mark we don't really know how
far I don't think we will be fully there
the world is not ready they sold it in
Copenhagen there have been steps taken
since Copenhagen to improve the
realization that we are in this together
and now there is agreement that a
climate agreement should cover every
country it's not something that can be
sold only by the previous industrialized
rich countries yeah because the rest of
the world is growing and they have grown
far above the emissions from the OECD
countries so now the two big emitters US
and China they were both holding back
and certainly China was in Copenhagen
saying no to be committed and to be kind
of reined in they we need development
you know all of that but and then they
did make one important decision in
Copenhagen including with the Chinese
leader every country signed up to we
must avoid more than 2 degree Celsius
increase in world temperature average
yeah but by 2050 that was an important
first step
so Copenhagen was not it was a learning
experience that everyone had to realize
we have to try to do this differently
but they did make this important
decision then new steps have been taken
so including the one to say now a
climate agreement has to include us all
not with exactly the same expectations
depending on the level of development
but everyone has to be involved we all
have to be part of the solution and now
the two big ones have discussed both to
be coming forward and making their
commitments to the Secretariat in front
of the meeting in Paris they should have
been there already
but III think in the spring this year
they will both be coming with their
commitments which then what does that
mean it's very important that the two of
them have talked together and agreed
that both of them have to be part of the
solution it means many countries who
have been lining up behind us or China
saying no way we will not change we will
not because you know forced to change by
by outside forces look at they don't do
it data everyone has been pointing to
others now China has left a position
where other countries of the developing
world can say we don't need to and the
same with the u.s. other rich countries
who have said no we are not moving until
the US no they now have to move so with
all this - all together I guess that we
will have May
we're kind of a 60% answer by every
country announcing what they are
planning to do but we will have a gap
between between what we need and what
countries commit to yeah
now then and I'm sure this means
principles will be discussed about how
to move from this level to the necessary
level in that Paris meeting and in front
of it so I'm sure you know we will we
lift it up towards a hundred mark
somehow and and so I'm hopeful about the
Paris okay well with that hopeful
thought dr. Brundtland thank you very
much for speaking with us thank you so
much thank you